يمكن أن يكون الأمر مربكًا حقًا
عندما تكون في صيدلية تسير في
ذلك الممر وترى الكثير من
الخيارات التي يجب عليك حقًا التركيز عليها أكثر على
مستوى عامل الحماية من الشمس (SPF) عندما يصل إلى 70،
فمن الصعب فرك هذه المنتجات لمعرفة ذلك
المدلى بها  تترك على بشرتي تتراوح درجة
Sweet Spot بين 30 و50.
وذلك عندما يتم فركها بشكل جيد، وهذه هي
كمية ضوء الأشعة فوق البنفسجية B التي تعتبر مثالية
لحجبها بمجرد أن ترتفع إلى أعلى من ذلك، وهي
ثانية لا تذكر جدًا، فأنت تبحث
عن نطاق واسع و  هذا
شيء ستراه مكتوبًا بوضوح على
الملصق واسع النطاق وسيخبرك
أنه سيغطي كلاً من الأشعة فوق البنفسجية الطويلة (UVA) والأشعة فوق البنفسجية (
UVB) الخفيفة، والأشعة فوق البنفسجية (UVA) التي تعمر الجلد، والأشعة فوق البنفسجية (B) هي التي تحرق
بشرتك معًا
وتسبب سرطان الجلد، لذلك تريد حقًا
البحث عنها  شيء واسع النطاق،
ما هي مدة مقاومة الماء بشكل
مثالي إذا كنت تبحث عن 40 دقيقة
بالإضافة إلى 80 دقيقة بالإضافة إلى ذلك، فهو أفضل إذا
كنت تميل إلى الخروج على الشاطئ أو
في حمام السباحة مع الأطفال، والأهم من ذلك،
التقطه و  نوع من قراءة
العلامات الرئيسية، فهل هو واقي شمسي فيزيائي أم
كيميائي، واقيات الشمس الفيزيائية
هي بالتأكيد أفضل من المواد الكيميائية، لذا
إذا كنت تميل إلى الحرق عند الخروج في
الشمس، فأنت تريد حقًا تجربة
واقي الشمس الفيزيائي الذي يعكس
ضوء الأشعة فوق البنفسجية  من سطح الجلد
ثم واقيات الشمس الكيميائية التي
تمتص الأشعة فوق البنفسجية على سطح
الجلد، أرسل
لي أجنبي صورًا وسألني هل هذا
المنتج الذي ستستخدمه،
ستوصي به طبيب الأمراض الجلدية الخاص بك، وينبغي أن
يكون محطتك الأولى لذلك  خطوة
سلوكية في نهاية اليوم،
هناك أشياء نفعلها جميعًا مثل الذهاب إلى صالة
الألعاب الرياضية، واستخدام خيط تنظيف الأسنان، ووضع واقي الشمس
كل يوم على مدار 365 يومًا، هو
تغيير سلوكي آخر يمكنك
القيام به للحفاظ على صحتك.